DEBI CABRERA: Do you need
to monitor and protect
large amounts of sensitive
data, but aren't always
sure where that
data is or how it's
being processed and managed?
Today we'll talk about
Automatic DLP, a service
from Google Cloud that
is built to minimize
the risk of sensitive data
being mishandled or exposed
and help you prevent
privacy, security,
and compliance issues.
Before we continue, if you need
a refresher on what data loss
prevention is,
check out the link
in the description for our
Getting Started with Data Loss
Prevention playlist.
First, let's understand
how DLP Inspection works.
The Cloud DLP Engine inspects
structured and unstructured
data and classifies it using
what we call info types,
our predefined data tags.
Out of the box, DLP provides
over 150 different info types,
including personally
identifiable information,
financial data types, global
and region-specific types,
and more.
And you can extend these with
custom info types and detection
rules to meet your
business's needs.
For example, the DLP
Engine can tell you
where it found an instance
of a credit card number,
even giving you details
down to the byte
offset where it was found.
For BigQuery, an
inspection job can
be configured to scan an
individual table in a data set.
This will leverage
the DLP Engine
to perform a deep
scan of that table
to look for sensitive
data elements.
Info type classification
can be used
to make informed decisions
about how you protect, share,
and use your data.
The DLP Engine and
inspection jobs
are great at deep
scanning data to get
very detailed information.
But when it comes to
gaining visibility
across your entire organization,
across thousands of projects
filled with data
sets and tables,
this scale can become
unmanageable pretty quickly.
And writing up some custom
code to scan every table
can lead to a lot of
overhead to manage.
So we made DLP automatic and
developed a fully-managed data
profiling service that takes
away that overhead and pain.
It gives you the same
detection quality as DLP
and lets you protect
data by identifying
where sensitive and high-risk
data resides automatically.
It generates a set of metrics
and insights or a data profile
from scanning the data.
Among these metrics are
the protected info types
found in BigQuery tables,
free text score, and data risk
level.
So you gain crucial insights
into what kind of at-risk data
you are currently
storing, allowing
you to take the appropriate
steps to protect it.
Automatic DLP profiler
scans are set up
with a simple configuration.
And we'll scan all BigQuery
data sets and tables
in an entire organization,
folder, or project.
You may be thinking, these wide
scanning capabilities sound
great.
But what if I want to keep
that detailed view of my data?
Well, you're in luck because
this automatic service
was built to fit perfectly
with the previous DLP
functionality, those inspection
jobs we talked about earlier.
So you can get a
view a mile wide,
and when needed, a mile deep
when using these together.
And the fact that automatic
DLP is fully managed
allows Google Cloud to
take on the overhead
and allows you to focus on the
outcomes and your business.
But wait, there's more.
Continuous monitoring
automatically
profiles any new tables
you create across your org
and periodically re-profiles
the tables you modify.
Data profiles are generated in
the same geographical region
that your data lives in,
making sure to maintain
your data residency.
And deep technical knowledge
of coding or embedding
isn't necessary to
use the service.
You focus on configuring
it to your needs,
turning it on with one click,
and consuming the results.
And you get all of this
with low overhead, which
means you don't need to manage
or orchestrate your own jobs.
So scanning across
your org is a breeze.
As a quick example,
let's say you
have 150,000 tables
across multiple projects
that you need to scan
for sensitive data,
like Social Security
numbers and email addresses.
When you turn on
automatic DLP, you'll
see detailed metrics about
each table and column
in your organization so that
you can assess your overall data
risk and gain insights on where
you have that sensitive data.
Executives who worry about
maintaining security and data
compliance can see at a high
level where risks may lie.
And data admins who are
responsible for that data
can ensure all data is
properly permissioned
or consider they're
identifying the data
to protect it and
improve compliance.
All that were just
a few configuration
steps and the click of
a button to turn it on--
easy peasy.
So let's recap.
Automatic DLP will help find
sensitive data, including
unexpected places, keep
up with data growth that
makes it difficult to
manually inspect data,
and provide rich insights
about data and data risk,
allowing you to
manage data risk,
make more informed decisions,
focus on the outcome,
and ultimately, help to safely
accelerate your business
while we take care of the rest.
Thanks for watching.